um
[Music]
[Applause]
so sam's still in iceland and jake and i
have a whole bunch of work we got to do
let's try to get these bigger projects
off the ground so we need some help to
pull off the next video now gabe has a
bit of an animation background and wren
obviously has a great visual background
and peter no one knows what his
background is actually like but the
thing is we asked them to get together
and design the stop-motion action scene
for the next video i'm curious to see
what they come up with i'm sure it'll be
a mish-mash of a bunch of different cool
ideas
how is your night
so we've had some foam swords lying
around the office for a while now a few
years back i took some kendo so did sam
actually carmichael asked me if i could
show him a few tips and tricks and how
to be a better swordsman so let's all
learn how to fight with katanas foam
katanas the philosophy behind fighting
with the katana is that if you take a
swing they're going to take a swing back
at you so you have to win the fight in
that single swing you don't really get a
lot of like
stuff going on when you're doing katana
fighting usually it's you find your
target you wait for that opening and
once you see it you strike
you move in to the fight because when
you close that distance and you get up
close then it's hard for people to hit
you with their sword range is very very
important knowing where you are and the
distance that you can cover with one
step
is very important i can tell that
carmichael if he wants to cannot get to
me from here from here if he wants to
he'll probably get to me but i have a
lot of time to react from here either
one of us could quickly take out the
other person and just be a matter of
fact you know a quick swing did you
focus up the sword you you trusted my
sword into me
so yesterday was all about figuring out
the logistics of how to actually shoot
this video getting the camera getting
whatever props we need stuff like that
kind of really nailed out the skeleton
of the piece like what are the big
moments how does the video play out how
does it wrap back to the beginning this
guy comes tumbling out oh
spaceman boom lands in the dock the dog
literally splats this person's like oh
my god my dog either the portal has
closed and reopens or is just sitting
open
and that could be something like just a
bunch of like black sheets wrapped up
like you're trying to sneak out of a
bedroom or something right
yeah actually that looks pretty cool i
think
if we do it jankily enough people will
just accept the jankiness and believe in
the story that we're making and
watch for the cool choreography assuming
we can make choreography that's cool
enough so that's what we're doing today
so the camera will be plugged in the
cable go over and then down to a
computer or we'll be able to actually
see a live view preview of the image and
ideally we're going to get some software
that will allow us to use what's called
onion skinning onion skinning is the
ability to see the previous frame
overlaid on top of the current frame
this is really handy for stop motion
because you're moving things a little
bit by little bit
controlling the center is also important
i can push carmichael off to the side
and now he's completely open for me to
do whatever i want to but then he's also
gonna be fighting to get the center as
well so you start kind of getting in
this pushing match right and one of the
cool things you can do is one of my
favorite counters is you just drop your
sword and the person over corrects and
it's just a matter of a little step
forwards and look right on the wrist
keeping an eye on somebody's eyes is
very important you'll see what they're
about to go for so i'll see if i can
maybe look down i'm like better watch my
feet
you also kind of see when they're about
to commit to a hit and the moment
somebody winds up if you are ready you
can get in there and strike and close
that distance before they can get that
hit in the same thing if they wind up
and they swing through and you dodge
that the moment that sword passes you
you change momentum and you're in and
close and you get that hit really fast
and like finding that rhythm and finding
those moments is like that's the most
satisfying part about the sword fight
thank you this will fill all of our
needs i mean
okay yeah that air it's showing it's
just not taking the photo
we lost like three photos
two to three most creepy most recent
ones or yeah most recent yeah
all right so let's go back to the last
known photo well we gotta solve the
problem because here i'll just take a
photo and
look what happens
photometric tag is missing assuming data
is ycbcr
samples per pixel tag is missing
applying correct samples per pixel value
of three assuming sub sampling inside
jpeg data is correct
and those are all the warnings we're
getting per photo
per photo and we don't know why it's
doing that we don't know how to fix it
no it's like compression it's jpeg
compression stuff that i don't
understand
okay uh let's go to google
we are running very far behind it is now
3 p.m on tuesday and we've not even
really shot the intro did it work
so wait however
it's not processing the raw data we're
just getting jpegs but it's faster now
right way better yeah how should you
stand well you can do you hold the sword
right here on the top left hand on the
bottom but your left foot is back and up
on your toes here so you can spring
forwards if you're moving around and
your legs are crossed all it takes is a
little bump from the other person and
you trip over yourself and fall over you
start working on that
where you
learn to
move around without keeping your legs
crossed
yeah
yeah
move with your right leg you're going
right move with your left leg
that's about all you need to know so for
those of you who actually practice kando
i apologize for probably massacring a
whole bunch of techniques possibly even
spreading some misinformation definitely
encourage you guys to you know throw out
tips and corrections and anything else
comments in the description it's always
fun reading that stuff you guys can
watch the fight yeah man i'm here to
spectate your blood
we're plagued by issues nico's writing
tether sam who knows where sam is it's
literally just the three of us working
on this video we need a lot more help
all right everyone ready peter all right
three two one
every single frame we've gotta move with
all the tentacles the eyes the portal
effects
so every frame we go in remove
everything so
[Music]
rather than like prepare the uh derek
are you listening
huh
oh what i can't tell that you're
sleeping oh sorry what's going on
my last frame i was like this uh first
off tonight make sure you get at least
seven hours of sleep yeah that's like a
requirement eight hours what we're gonna
do is this is gonna like flip around
and hit you in the head oh my god
so derek is playing
me five minutes from now we look fairly
similar when you have the math we have
very similar builds except we're about
the same height
yeah he is six one me two
[Music]
those wooden planks we have on the floor
we have to redo the entire video
from the top guys
[Music]
make sure to like subscribe and share
and uh rate this video make sure to rate
this video five star rating please video
rate
i completely misheard that
come on
what's in his mind these days i know too
much physics too much lying on floors
[Music]
now listen
yeah now i hear a lot a lot of requests
we're not going to play both right now
i'm going to bet on niko
seems like niko's doing most of the
training
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but no gps i'm underfunded and it's
functional like cps despite the forks in
this road ship we be blessed cause any
time i overheat the beats release
[Music]
got a solid strike in my arm but he got
with the flat of his sword
so just tilt it a little bit he would
have chopped my arm off thereby
eliminating my head strike meets the
living dead
you test me and i'll slip the head of
mister in your bed
that's it
all right let's go see what sam has to
say about kendo fighting so sound design
since this video doesn't have vfx i
figured you might want to know a little
bit about sound a lot of our videos are
musically driven which means the music
is the key sound that drives the energy
from beginning to end the sound effects
the dialogue they really only have two
jobs one emphasize the moments that are
cued visually
[Music]
and two make sure the viewer understands
the story for example when the wrens are
teleporting everywhere the first couple
times you hear the sound of the
teleporter it's going to be louder than
the rest this lets us go oh okay new
device new tool new science thingy
as they start teleporting more i start
dipping the sound of the teleporter that
way you can get back to the musical
energy that's driving the piece these
speakers these are pretty hardcore
studio speakers i don't want that i do
most of my editing is sound placement
five dollar samsung earbuds they mostly
come with android phones by default
they're small they're not bad they
mostly carry the highs and mids after
the earbuds i actually go to mixing on
forty dollar speakers that we got off
amazon they carry most of the lows and
other mids that my earbuds didn't
together they actually do that but for
45 bucks instead of hundreds of bucks
dears most of you are watching your
videos not with
massive speakers and a perfect sound
room like a theater by using the five
dollar headphones and forty dollar
speakers it lets me hear the sounds like
you will something i was trying out on
this mix that i haven't done before
is use this it's a sandisk i expand
flash drive uh made in china i'm not
being paid by sandisk to uh to mention
this this is just really interesting i
got this at vidcon with this lightning
port i can quickly transfer my sound
files from my computer to my phone i can
listen to it on the phone with a mono
speaker i can actually find moments that
aren't working sounds that i can't hear
because speaker is a completely
different quality i actually had to
change out all the wishes that you hear
in the video because they couldn't be
heard on an iphone i left a lot of
things out here i'm down to talk about
the sounds sound effects the programs
all that technical stuff about this
video or even the star wars drone video
or another one but that takes a lot of
time so it's probably going to be a live
hangout on patreon so we're trying
something new with this video we wanted
to make a list of our top 10 stop-motion
videos that inspire us and share them
with you guys because
who doesn't want to watch some sweet
videos right anyways if you want to
check out our favorites click this link
right here and it'll take you to a
playlist and sit back and enjoy a
non-stop stream of really cool
stop-motion videos have fun